dreieinhalb meter brust aufgereiht auf
einer kabeltrommel für 15 euro da kann
man auf jeden fall nicht mehr kann und
was ja auch noch ganz wichtig ist es
muss ja wenigstens einmal probieren aber
nicht sonst nie so der muss typen leute
doktor logistik
[Musik]
willkommen bei einem neuen video da
hatte ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut mir nicht weil folgendes ich habe
genau dieses video gestern abend schon
einmal aufgenommen mit juri der jetzt
heute in den urlaub gefahren ist und das
war eigentlich schon so weit fertig das
problem an der sache war als nur ich
wollte mich heute morgen mindestens ganz
entspannt das video schneiden und mir
ist aufgefallen der ton war irgendwie
manchmal an und manchmal aus das heißt
wir haben dann eigentlich vollständiges
video ohne ton und das ist natürlich ein
bisschen blöd deswegen wie das jetzt
mein erstes video sein was ich praktisch
hälfte hälfte verbände also ich muss das
ganze natürlich jetzt noch mal aufnehmen
um es dann mit dem anderen abzugleichen
weil ich ein paar sachen auch aus dem
anderen brauch jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon gelesen es geht heute um die
verrücktesten erstens produkte die man
auf amazon kaufen kann
und die habe ich halt alles schon
bestellt auch alle schon einmal geöffnet
alle schon einmal probiert das ganze
video war also eigentlich schon fertig
und jetzt müssen wir das ganze halt
einfach nochmal machen weil der sound
halt ziemlich beschädigt war ich hoffe
das versteht ihr und nehme es mir nicht
übel ich gebe mein bestes
bevor wir jetzt anfangen wollte ich euch
erstmal alle sachen zeigen damit dass am
meisten sinn ich bin noch diese idee
aufgrund eines produktes gestoßen das
wird irgendwie zufällig angezeigt und
zwar handelt es sich dabei um moment ich
lade euch das hier war ein eine wie soll
ich sagen aufgerollte wurst auf einer
kabeltrommel die dreieinhalb meter lang
ist ja das war nicht so verrückt das
habe ich direkt angestellt und habe
ungefragt dass er mir doch mal bitte
weitere verrückte sachen zu schicken
sollte das habt ihr wirklich in vielzahl
gemacht also danke dafür auf dem zweirad
könnt ihr sehr gern mitzuschicken auf
instagram heißt alex wie ihr habt mir
zum beispiel geschickt das finde ich
eigentlich das heftigste snack insekt
getrocknete grashüpfer auch hier sehr
gern mal ein foto wie gesagt ich hab das
gestern alles schon mal probiert blende
ich euch gleich sehr gerne auch ein dann
haben wir noch ganz verrückt es war
grillkohle da reicht auch sehr gespannt
was das denn ist das probleme gleich
auch noch mal
und zu guter letzt hat mir gegen den
mädels ein geburtstagsgeschenk also
weitermachen das ist ein
erste-hilfe-kasten mit ganz viel
medikamenten was mich da erwartet bin
ich auch immer gespannt um diese viele
sachen geht es heute ich würde sagen wie
lange schlange fahren direkt mal an alle
produkte sind auch in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und wenn was
staaten waren gestern habe ich auch mit
diesem medizin kasten angefangen hier
sind irgendwie ganz viele medikamente
drin
ich würde sagen das gute ist wir haben
komplett guten sound bei dieser aufnahme
wir es wird schon noch mal kurz hin
damit ihr das checkt und ja wirklich ein
sehr außergewöhnliches produkt geben was
für messer oder so
[Musik]
das hat mir nun willst du mich nachts
vier umbringen oder was hörst du das
und in diesem erste hilfe kasten
denn medikamente drin wie zum beispiel
aspirin oder so glaube ich was man einem
an kopfschmerzen hat nur halt als
süßigkeiten verpackt und wie das
aussieht schaut mal rein ich bin
wirklich gespannt mehr malta die
subjekte daneben
[Gelächter]
sie war war es dieser edition ist
wirklich eine geballte enden
ich habe für diese oralen anwendung wenn
du mal wieder zu dieser wird das ist
jetzt aber nicht vermittelt oder das ist
ja nur eine süßigkeit du bist nicht du
wenn du nicht bist anwendungshinweise
hinsetzen packungen aufreißen
schokoriegel verlängern
du bist wieder da ja super ins netz okay
aber darum geht es also so jetzt habe
ich verstanden ich dachte dass ich wie
ich dachte das richtige zu tun als wenn
deswegen habe ich doch verstellt du
kannst doch auch nicht sonst kann man
noch nicht mal was und ich dachte die
haben sowieso apfel mittel vielleicht in
sneakers rein gemacht dass du
entscheiden muss man unbedingt
also ich habe jetzt wirklich auch erste
sein etwas besserem gerechter als wenn
wir glück haben noch mal einen auf du
wirst in zwei monaten die eine million
abonnenten auf youtube klappen
das geht alles wie muss los das einzige
was jetzt gerade halt noch drin ist es
schlaflosen mit pfefferminz geschmack
und antibiotikum
lustiger war schon mal da steht halt
wirklich antibiotikum berlin schreibt
man am anfang mit b und hinten mit h
stimmt zum ersten produkt wir haben ja
gestern schon festgehalten
irgendwie ein bisschen lustig und für 16
euro
auch ganz schön teuer aber verrückt
genug um es mit in dieses video format
zu nehmen aber jetzt noch mit etwas mut
du hast noch nie getrocknete kräuter wir
sehen oder ich hab mir gestern wirklich
auch zum ersten mal gesehen hier haben
wir auf soundbite also ihr welt gleich
wieder den original ausschnitt von
gestern sehen was man auch lecker oder
und das haben wir halt auch gestern
gemacht wir haben einfach mal diesen
grashüpfer aufgeschnitten um zu sehen
was den song grashüpfer eigentlich drin
ist also dass nachher wird das video
jetzt hier als nicht mehr freundlich
gekennzeichnet aber da haben wir auch
schon gesagt das sieht eigentlich aus
wie sein stroh und strohhalme also
komplett wie stroh also ist
wahrscheinlich gerade in originalen
ausschnitt von gestern gesehen und da
habe ich auch gesagt dass ich das am
ende probiere weil ich war wirklich
extrem geschockt davon und dachte so
etwas hast du dir hier vorgenommen und
wir kommen zum nächsten verrückten
essens produkt und zwar essbare
grillkohle konnte ich mir auch gar
nichts drunter vorstellen was das
eigentlich sein soll
ich muss sagen ich bin mir gerade
unsicher ob wir da vernünftige
soundqualität haben deswegen probiere
ich das jetzt einfach noch mal ich weiß
noch wie es schmeckt also das ist so
zeigt sieht aus wie grillkohle und man
kann es anscheinend essen
ob das funktioniert weiß ich nicht
schick das mal machen wir das noch
vorsichtig auch finde ich extrem lustig
kostet fünf euro die packung und hier
haben wir halt einfach marshmallows mit
so zusätzlich zucker und zogen und das
ist halt wirklich aus wie grillkohle und
da habe ich besser gesagt das merkt
wirklich verdanken eigentlich bin ich
gar nicht so der marshmallow
aber dieses verrückte produkt überzeugen
sollte das gute ist genau gerade wir
haben 15 uhr 48 das video kommt heute
und 19 online ist das paket angekommen
weshalb ich schon gesagt eigentlich
dieses ganze video mache oder ich war
auf die idee gekommen bin und zwar haben
wir hier drin
diese wurst kabeltrommel die es anderen
auch in ganz vielen verschiedenen
designs gibt ich bin wirklich mal
gespannt was da drin ist und was ich
mich direkt schon gefragt habt also wenn
man das jetzt mal so vergleicht das ist
ja nicht groß auf dem bild schaut euch
mal das bild an meiner meinung nach
sieht das deutlich größer aus deswegen
ja mal schauen ob insgesamt 15 euro
gekostet für dreieinhalb meter
wurststand da glaube ich bei ok
ungeöffnet ungekühlt mindestens eine vor
allem das lustig ist ja ob wir haben
gerade draußen in köln wirklich 40 grad
und man merkt ist an diesen dingen es
extrem heiß trotzdem steht drauf
ungekühlt mindestens haltbar bis 1912 19
das habe ich mir bestellt es stellt sich
nur die frage wie man das auch krieg
also hier muss ich wirklich sagen das
ist ein extrem verrücktes produkt ich
habe keine ahnung was ich davon halten
soll
aber was man sagen muss man muss ja auch
erstmal auf die idee kommen und hier
sind anscheinend wirklich dreieinhalb
meter muss darauf sich das mal
ausprobieren sollen wir daraus ziehen
du kannst das fest
endlich gefasst mainz kommt ungefähr
dreieinhalb meter brust aufgeräumt auf
einer kabeltrommel für 15 euro da kann
man auf jeden fall nicht meckern und was
ja noch ganz wichtig jetzt muss ich ja
wenigstens einmal probieren
auch wenn ich sonst nie so der wurst
typen schwierig wahrscheinlich wie viel
oder so was
nur schmeckt original wie viel
vielleicht nicht ganz so gut aber
geschmäcker also da muss man auch sagen
irgendwann euro für 300 meter brust
absolut gerechtfertigt ist ein cooles
dinge also verlängert ihr euch auch in
der beschreibung zeigt dass auf jeden
fall mal und dann würde ich sagen frau
wird zum nächsten vernetzungsprojekt wir
probieren jetzt mal die gekoppelten
rasch schutzräume und jetzt muss ich
durch den hopper eigentlich noch mal
durch ich habe gestern schon so eine
halben grashüpfer probiert weil ich
nicht weiß ich zeige euch jemand in
ausschnitten ich hoffe wir haben gute
soundqualität falls nicht nehmen wir das
nicht übel
hier haben wir das nette produkt auch
schon grashüpfer getrocknet snack insekt
haltbar bis 10 12 2009 ca
was das habe ich völlig zurück wirklich
jetzt erst ist es sich hier um echte
insekten handelt
schließlich will man dabei nicht also
das ist doch ein perfektes
geburtstagsgeschenk
ihr könnt mir egal in die kommentare
schreiben ob mir sowas schon mal
probiert habt und hab ich vielleicht mal
ein ganzes video zu so getrocknete
insekten von amazon drehen soll falls ja
dass man fett nach oben da ich würde
sagen ich denke jetzt gar nicht lange
darüber nach und es einfach noch diesen
letzten grashüpfer um diesen geschmack
noch einmal zu haben dass es nur so eine
überwindung
wir haben das ist ja wirklich so
leichtes ding womit flügel leute für
mich wie im dschungelcamp
naja zwar nicht wenigstens sagen ich
habe schon mal in meinem leben einen
grashüpfer gegessen
einen ganzen hier muss man auch sagen
der ganze packung hat glaube ich 13 euro
kostet wenn ich dann schon teuer für so
ein paar grashüpfer wie werden die
eigentlich produziert haben gibt es da
so eine gras zu verfahren die sich auch
super spezialisieren oder das ist
irgendwie auch verrückt also ich muss
ganz klar sagen das ist für mich mit
abstand das verrückteste essens produkt
was man dort bestellen
falls ihr noch mehr kennt dann lass mich
das auf jeden fall wissen schickte mir
bei instagram 30 alex wie können zweiten
tag denken doch nach oben
da machen wir das und wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr wieder gibt es neues video
haut rein